bonjour
il fait beau cet après midi j'avais vous
paraît envie de vous parler d'art
alors ça peut vous surprendre je suis
pas là pour vous parler de l'art pour
l'art ce que formule de flaubert quand
il raconte que dans l'écriture de salon
bau ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
créer un pourpre un rouge et ils sont
fichés de la géographie de l'histoire de
l'intrigué maintenant ça je laisse ça
aux grands artistes j'ai plutôt là pour
vous parler de comment l'art peut créer
un imaginaire une vision et donc demain
nous inviter à construire votre start up
donc ça c'est un lieu à paris qui
s'appelle le laboratoire près du palais
royal qui sert à incuber et qui part
toujours de larges vais revenir un peu
plus en détails
alors là sa puissance c'est de nous
aider à imaginer l'exemple évidemment le
plus connu c'est un léonard de vinci
sont codex la mousse ses fulgurances sur
l'hélicoptère
le temps que la mitrailleuse plein de
choses donc voilà ça c'est très bien
même si le problème c'est que là il faut
quelques siècles avant que ça se
transforme
nous ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est que
en quelques mois quelques semaines on
arrive à passer d'une intuition
artistique à un projet qui puisse se
traduire dans la vie des gens et je vais
vous dire un petit peu comment avant de
prendre des exemples concrets
je vais vous parler d'une personne
puisque dans la vie en deux temps en
temps fait on parlait de rencontre on
fait des rencontres sentimentales il ya
des coups de foudre
il ya aussi des coups de foudre
professionnel moi j'étais en charge des
innovations chez coca-cola coca-cola
c'est une compagnie extraordinaire pour
la gestion de marques pour l'invention
marketing il ya un département new
ventures qui avait été créé pour un hic
incubé différemment parce qu'évidemment
lancé un coca cola zero c'est un modèle
de blockbusters si je prends une
analogie de cinéma lancé une petite
boisson légumes c'est plutôt du film
haute du film d'auteur et ça doit pas
marcher la même manière en travaillant
j'avais vu un jour passer un article
d'un professeur food harvard qui avait
ce projet le faire une innovation
particulière dont je parlais juste après
j'en dis pas plus pour l'instant
et deux jours après j'ai démissionné je
le rejoignais parce que non pas
seulement la solution qu'il avait à
coeur de porter que je vais vous
expliquer mais surtout par la manière
dont ils voulaient y arriver qui était
le plus intéressant quand je dis manière
d'y arriver c'est de se dire que le
drame des grands groupes
je peux en témoigner c'est que souvent
la r&d parce qu'il faut donner de la
matière aux ingénieurs la r&d est tiré
par l'insight par le consommateur
le marketing et le drame du consommateur
c'est que forcément il quand on lui pose
une question sur l'avenir ils le
regardent au travers de son expérience
ont quelque part et juge l'avenir avec
l'oeil dans le rétroviseur
donc c'est pas génial c'est la fameuse
formule d'henry ford si on avait demandé
à la fin du 19ème aux gens comment ont
voyagé plus vite ils ont répondu des
calèches avec plus de chevaux donc ça ça
peut pas marcher
et donc si on veut pas faire d'un
crémone de l'innovation incrémentale
mais un vrai changement de modèle un
changement de paradigme ce qu'il appelle
des blue ocean l insee had et bien dans
ce cas là il faut avoir un regard
différent et donc la conviction de david
edwards ce qui m'a vraiment séduit c'est
à dire qui sont les gens les plus
créatifs au monde ce sont les artistes
dont créons un lieu littéralement
adjacent au laboratoire d'électronique
et de food où on invite des artistes art
artiste au sens large ça peut être un
design comme star qui est un chef comme
thierry marx un peintre comme fabrice
hyber etc et surtout ce qui est très
important on les invite à venir faire
une exposition mais sans leur dire sur
quoi il faut travailler parce que sinon
ça et ça casse tout pour l'avoir vu chez
coca cola a les consommateurs
comprennent pas bien l'aspartame
il y avait malgré les études ils ont des
doutes donc ici on trouvait un
édulcorant naturel pour but c'est ça ou
est aujourd'hui coca cola life donc
quelque part la solution est déjà dans
la question est donc évidemment ça va ça
ne pas être très innovant donc ça
permettait à des belles choses mais pas
de changer de modèle
là la différence c'est de dire 'voilà
venez avec votre projet est derrière la
seule condition qu'on vous donne pour la
collaboration pour vous accueillir dans
nos murs et que vous il faut que vous
soyez ouverts à travailler avec des
ingénieurs pour se dire comment est ce
que ce projet ponctuel parisien local
limité dans le temps pourrait demain
avoir un impact positif dans la vie les
gens partant de ce cahier des charges
assez minimales donc les gens arrivent
avec leur projet les gens les artistes
est derrière mais petit à petit on
essaie de comprendre ce qu'ils ont voulu
faire et à dire tiens à huy et dans la
vie de tous les jours est ce que ça
pourrait pas induire telle ou telle
expérience
je vais vous donner deux exemples
concrets un premier qui est encore en
cours de développement qui sort cet été
et un deuxième qui est déjà sur le
marché
donc celui ci il est assez c'est assez
amusant c'est une technologie
avant de vous dire ce que c'est je vais
vous raconter sa jeunesse parce que si
on comprendrait pas pourquoi je vous
parle d'art pareil on a rencontré un
plasticien allemand carsten nicolas est
très connu bon déjà un peu un peu pointu
qui son projet c'est à dire comment les
gens pouvaient partager des émotions
quand ils n'avaient pas accès au langage
et encore moins à l'écriture donc si je
caricature avec mes mots à moi mais ce
n'est pas comme ça qu'est le disais
c'est quand l'homme préhistorique
voulais partager des émotions comment
ils pouvaient le faire donc là dessus il
crée un dispositif scénique avec des
cloches sensorielle avec des odeurs
couplée à des images et effectivement
quand on se retrouve sous une cloche à
un moment on était en pleine vitalité un
autre on était angoissé un autre moment
ont été relaxés donc ça marchait assez
bien bon ça c'est son projet artistique
très bien il faut le vivre pour le
ressentir
par contre plus fondamentalement ce
qu'on trouvait intéressant avec lui
c'est de se dire tiens ok pour pour
pouvoir développer les relations les
gens qui travaillent beaucoup sur il y
avait tout un travail sur l'odeur est à
dire aujourd'hui comment est-ce que les
gens communiquent principalement par le
smartphone à c'est un pas de chance
l'odeur c'est le grand absent du
smartphone l'odeur c'est le moment
absent d'oculus de la réalité virtuelle
donc si on veut passer un cran supérieur
dans la capacité d'immersion et de
connexion et si on a traduisez les
odeurs alors là il faut un peu
d'innocence parce que voilà un travail
et les odeurs c'est quelque chose qui
est un vieux serpent de mer qui existe
depuis très longtemps avec des
tentatives parfois hilarantes
on peut pas dire parce que ça n'existe
pas c'est pas possible donc voilà on
retrousse les manches donc il ya pas mal
d ingénieur brillant qui ont travaillé
là dessus au côté david edwards c'est
rachel fil d'une personne d'harvard très
forte et donc petit à petit est arrivé
le premier prototype que je vous
présente derrière c'est une sorte de
dire penser un peu à une imprimante en
lesquels vous mettez des cartouches
couleur malaval à penser à une sorte de
petite enceinte qui au lieu de balancer
du son doit balancer les odeurs et à
l'intérieur il ya des cartouches qui
sont pas les cartouches d'encre mais des
cartouches de fragrances ce qui fait que
quelque part vous avez un mini orgue à
parfum avec vous pour pouvoir derrière
relâché relâcher les odeurs et donc ça
marche par le smartphone donc ça veut
dire que il ya un codage électronique
qui fait que voilà j'ai envie d'envoyer
voilà imaginons j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle à partager
j'ai une petite fille qui arrive est une
petite fille qui arrive je vais envoyer
la photo je t'ai avec ma photo avec une
odeur de célébration ils ont le
champagne parce qu'on est en france et
la personne qui le reçoit
elle va avoir à la fois la photo et en
même temps va avoir cette couche de
sensationnel quelque part une presque
une forme d'émoticônes qui va lui dire
tiens voilà c'est c'est quelque chose de
joyeux
donc ça c'est l'inter personnel après
bien sûr vous imaginez que le champ il
est assez énorme
si je prends le sabotier des industries
qu'est le plus caricatural là dessus
c'est le parfum le gros du budget par en
télé affichage digital c'est à dire des
endroits où forcément on ne sent pas le
produit qu'on présente alors ça vient on
a les femmes très belle souvent un peu
dévêtue dans un univers très onirique
mais ça donne quand même pas grand chose
aux consommateurs sur calais le produit
bon pour sa poêlée en magasin
l'otan entend ouvrir un magazine donc là
demain ça veut dire que de son canapé
on peut ou dans le métro je peux
derrière quoi voir voir une pub si je
fais un jeu vidéo mais mon immersion va
être renforcée on a vu à l'éco qu'ulysse
ya pas longtemps une vidéo fantastique
et on est derrière un pianiste arisman
en était on est vraiment l'impression
d'être dans la seine par contre le
pianiste à sa droite
il y avait un cendrier avec une fumée
avec une cigarette et des volutes de
fumée c'était à la fois très beau et en
même temps quand on s'approchait ça
faisait très fake parce que je sentais
pas l'odeur de la cigarette
si demain on peut rajouter 700 soit
forcément ce sens l'immersion va monter
d'un cran
on dit souvent une parole dans une image
au bien des maux sans doute que demain
on pourra dire une odeur vaut bien des
images par cette capacité à nous à nous
engager à l'ohl faction c'est le premier
sens développé à la naissance parce
qu'un enfant il est à moitié aveugle
c'est pas bien toucher etc
par contre il reconnaît très bien
l'odeur de l'odeur de sa mère mais petit
à petit ce sens est submergé par
d'autres sens qu'on s'est beaucoup mieux
travailler parce que l'impôt
électroniques envoyés du son de l'image
est beaucoup plus facile et ça explique
on va dire quelque part ce silence
assourdissant donc c'est bien d'avoir
des prototypes ne l'ait travail et de
les tester
quand j'ai détesté pour nous c'est
évidemment une étape essentielle
tellement essentiel que c'est la
troisième jambe du modèle j'ai dit il ya
on part d'une salle d'exposition on
essaye en labo de construire un
prototype et derrière on va tester avec
les gens dont pour tester
pour nous le mieux souvent le futur fait
peur parfois tout le monde s'est dit que
je vais être innovant mais en fait ça
s'est un peu peur c'est un peu flippant
ya un côté 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
donc ce qu'on a fait on a créé un café
zaman café sciences où les gens peuvent
entrer prendre un café manger tiens donc
c'est assez rassurant c'est cosy vous
voyez la photo
celui-là il est en fait quasiment en
face du hem haïti à boston et et
derrière par contre on va leur proposer
tient en fait est-ce que sur le menu
vous pouvez télécharger des zones de
vents forts là des choses qui sont
latéral et derrière ils vont pouvoir
tester et puis bien sûr de la partie au
moment où ils sont engagés là dessus ils
peuvent aussi pourront dans certains cas
acheter c'est génial parce qu'ils me
disent qu'ils comprennent la proposition
est-ce que l'ergonomie est bonne le prix
proposé - et c'est donc c'est ça nous
permet semaine après semaine
pas de faire des corrections de
trajectoire - ces moments les principes
de base du lean management mais c'est
vraiment on essaye on essaye on essaye
parce que la plupart d'entre vous qui
qui sont un peu un jour posé la question
de l'entrepreneuriat savent que c'est
difficile d'avoir le eureka le matin en
se levant avec la silver bullet où on
est au dessus dans la plaque non c'est
assez itératif on on essaye et petit à
petit on a juste on ajuste son jeu donc
voilà ça c'est un premier exemple
packaging je vais parler d'une solution
de chaque année juste après donc sur la
partie comment demain partager des
odeurs celles en cdd le printemps il ya
une exposition à new york et sera donc
ces mots là c'est un monde qui est en
train d'arriver est on en train de
travailler avec les les grands de
l'industrie automobile alf active du
foot donc probablement que demain si
c'est pas ça j'espère que d'autres y
arrivons parce que vraiment l'enjeu il
est là pour pour trouver des solutions
mais je pense qu'on a on a des bonnes
chances d'avancer autre sujet évidemment
c'est derrière une fois qu'on a fait
tout ça faut le faire connaître alors je
fais un petit retour vers le futur pour
expliquer le slayki au dessus de moi
autre sujet d'expositions culturelles on
avait un designer alimentaire qui
s'appelle françoise un beau il fait
beaucoup de bateaux et ça et ce avant
des fous sur la méditerranée de voir
tous ces déchets qui flottait en
plastique s'est dit tiens si je faisais
une exposition où mon angle c'était
regardons différemment le packaging donc
il avait créé ces superbes des
bouteilles d'eau pour fabriquer tous les
matins et on pouvait ont croqué le
bouchon derrière on pouvait voir la
bouteille puis si on avait faim ont
mangé la bouteille donc c'est génial
parce que je pense que goûte aussi je me
demande quel est le le meilleur
packaging monde peut sans doute beaucoup
sont d'accord avec moi pour dire que le
fruit à venir un grain de raisin c'est
le meilleur packaging parce que
finalement je mange la peau et donc il
n'y a aucun aucun déchet et si demain ce
que la nature fait tous les jours avec
les fruits dont on mange la peau on
pouvait le trans là tu es sur les
yaourts sur les glaces sur d'autres
produits ou derrière on pourrait avoir
le produit
encapsulé dans une peau naturelle de
fraise vanille de ce qu'on veut qu'on
lave sous l'eau et qu'on mange ce qui
fait que derrière en amont pas besoin
d'utiliser des ressources non
renouvelables et en aval rien de besoin
de mettre dans la poubelle donc on
attaque sérieusement le 2000 tonnes de
déchets que chaque ménage
ben chaque année en france donc derrière
beaucoup de on avait suivi les mêmes
étapes que la aux expositions prototype
test au café sciences etc
et puis voilà derrière quand on fait du
un boulot un peu consistant il ya des
temps en temps des récompenses qui
tombait puis qui nous facilite
évidemment beaucoup la vie avec les
investisseurs et industriels comme time
magazine qui chaque année vous savez
fait de son numéro l'homme de l'année et
a fait un numéro avec les 25 innovations
de l'année et on s'est retrouvés cité au
même niveau que oculus parmi les 25
l'innovation à suivre donc c'est assez
magique de voir comment un jour
quelqu'un en méditerranée qui aiment pas
les sacs en plastique qui flottent peut
demain arriver à une innovation reconnue
par time magazine
bien sûr derrière il faut c'est bien de
faire des pillards mais il faut délivrer
et donc pour dire que c'est pas que que
des rêves de fou d'art contemporain
voilà sept
cette initiative elle est aujourd'hui
distribuée qui s'appelle wiki futsal est
distribué
quel est mon plein et d'innovation
sociale et distribué par sony fils qui
est la filiale la plus organique enfin
la plus bio de danone
si vous connaissez innocence et nous
sentons beaucoup plus gros aux états
unis ça a démarré chez vous le foot ce
qui est la chaîne de supermarchés on va
dire un peu un peu bio un peu
responsable voilà au début toujours
pareil et ses essais progressive on a
démarré dans trois magasins ça marchait
bien on a développé dans une trentaine
entre philadelphie et boston ça continue
à bien marcher
le mois prochain les voix pour passer au
niveau national et si derrière ça
continue à bien marcher au niveau
national il ya des chances que ça parte
dans d'autres pays et voir dans d'autres
dans d'autres circuits derrière donc
voilà tout ça parce qu'à un moment un
artiste nous a mis sur les rails
on s'est pas levé levé un matin aux
radiations et du packaging hommes
estiment c'est en écoutant des gens qui
avaient des regards différents
que ça que ça nous a mis dans la bonne
dans la bonne direction
donc voilà j'en arrête là de ces
exemples mais c'est pour montrer que
c'est possible et que derrière voilà
tous les six mois on est un nouvel
artiste et donc tous les 6 mois
potentiellement on a une nouvelle
start-up qui qui se dégage
voilà pour boucler avec ce que je disais
au début le plus important la chance que
nous ouvre les artistes c'est de nous
construire nos imaginaires voilà il ya
un siècle
c'est moins loin que léonard de vinci
mais il ya deux autres français jules
verne et méliès bas qui nous un vin qui
nous a invités à aller sur la lune
depuis ça a inspiré beaucoup
d'ingénieurs et ça s'est transformé
l'idée c'est de se dire là qu on peut
raccourcir ses délais on entend un vrai
processus d'idéation pour mettre de
l'innovation dans votre business
il ya une phrase de céline que j'aime
beaucoup qui parle de littérature de
l'art pour dire que c'est la petite
musique qui fait danser la vie eh bien
j'espère qu'avec moi demain vous
penserez que l'art et la petite musique
qui peut faire danser votre business